Megan was the one that was really like
letting it go you know Idris Elba
reveals Meghan markle's secret skill and
it involves the Dance Floor 10 out of
10. the actor DJ'd Megan and her hubby
Prince Harry's wedding reception in
2018. it was so fun
feeling like a whirlwind it was so great
Idris tells ET Canada as he drops and
beats he got a front row seat to the
duchess's top-notch moves who was the
best dancer who like what celebrity out
there really had the moves oh uh do you
know what I was so nervous
I think Megan was the one that was
really letting it go you know she was a
girl um she just had a lot of fun it was
her wedding so she had the greatest time
I just really wanted the music to be fun
[Music]
was there any Beyonce on the place
[Laughter]
there's always Beyonce in the playlist
you already know that aside from queen
beat Megan and Harry also got down to
some Classics what team was the one that
got everyone going crazy I want to dance
with somebody of course they went off on
that tune yeah
um what else was there
um oh
um still still taking my time to perfect
the beat and I still got love for the
streets
really yeah I knew I liked them it's
Megan's children yeah so I kind of
approached my music as I do my acting I
don't like playing the same role twice
and I don't like to make the same sort
of song twice you know I know that's
like not for everyone people just like
to keep you in boxes but hey I just
really enjoy the process of making music
and you know and I hope people enjoy it
too not everyone loves it but hey I love
it I've been making music as long as I
in fact longer than uh myself as an
actor Idris is no doubt established
himself as an e-lister in Hollywood
three shocks will kill a man there we go
it's a bad guy speech
that's why it surprised many fans when
his DJ career kicked off in the 2010s
spinning at Big music festivals across
the world including Coachella
foreign
he has no plans of stopping making music
has just been something I just love to
do almost like a hobby and and then over
the years I've just been putting out
bits and pieces and and you know listen
when you've been playing other
characters for a long time it's really
nice to step into another Creative
Source where you can just be you and so
the music that comes out of you the
words that come out of you the emotion
is you right and I enjoy it
[Music]
thank you